hey everybody things are
really accelerating i have so much stuff
to play for you today i have memes we
are
waiting for kaylee mckennany at the top
of the hour
uh the rare early press briefing
in advance of donald trump having a
bunch of stuff on his schedule let me
actually pull up that schedule
um what does he have he
oh he's having lunch with mike pompeo
okay all right well listen it's
something
at least he's not merely sitting around
watching tv right is that something we
can say
uh okay yes where to even start
there's an interview with jonathan swann
from axios and it is
you know when we saw the chris wallace
interview two weeks ago
it seemed like maybe that was the worst
interview trump had ever done
until i saw the axios interview i don't
have time
for um i don't have time to play the
entire thing for you but i have a couple
of clips i also
oh hold on a second i also received
a video of trump i guess doesn't know
how to pronounce yosemite let's very
quickly look at that first and then
we'll look at some of the axios videos
gaze upon
yosemites yosemites towering
[Music]
yo semma heights the osema heights
oh my god uh oh people are saying my
volume is low that's weird
it should be where it where it always
has been that's really straight there's
no re it's maxed
um
oh it seems to be only one person who's
insisting on that
so maybe it's actually fine
anyway let's look at this again yosemite
heights
when they gaze upon yosemites yosemites
oh man it's it's too crazy um it's like
plasma
that's crazy all right so now let's go
to the axios interview now this is just
one clip
okay this already has 23 million views
this is
outrageous let's take a look and you're
going to see a confused trump handing
pieces of paper to jonathan swan he
doesn't understand what the papers are
it's just crazy take a look at
some of these charts i'd love to we're
going to look let's look and if you look
at death
yeah start to go up again
well right here the united states is
lowest
in numerous categories
uh we're lower than the world we're
lower than the world look at the expo oh
my god look at this pause look at the
expression i thought jonathan swann's
face
screenshot it that this is just i mean
that's crazy right
what we're lower than the world lower
the lower than
europe and what look in what take a look
right here here's case death
oh you're doing death as a proportion of
cases i'm talking about death as a
proportion of population
that's where the u.s is really bad much
worse than south korea germany et cetera
you can't you can't do that you have to
you have yeah as people
are pointing out on twitch 50 million or
60 million people are still going to
vote for the guy
you have to go by where look here is the
united states
you have to go by the cases the cases
why not as a proportional population
what it says is when you have somebody
that has
where there's a case oh okay the people
that live from
those cases it's surely a relevant
statistic to say if the us
has x population and x percentage of
death of that population no versus south
africa go by the cases we'll look at
south korea for example 51 million
population
it's funny because trump's argument is
mostly case numbers don't matter because
we test a lot
but he insists about talking about the
death rate
not in the context of the population but
in the context of cases like it's
it's completely incoherent three hundred
deaths it's like it's
crazy because i know that i do you don't
know you think they're faking their
statistics south korea
so this is a crutch i go into this on on
the clip that i just recorded
um this is an epistemological clutch
a crutch where at any time you can just
say do we really know anything
right and it's not particularly valuable
when at any time you can just say
anything we believe we know we might not
know
like okay if it's a philosophy class if
it's an epistemology class if it's a
um critical thinking class okay we would
talk about how do we know when we can
trust something but
to use it as a crutch in this way is a
really lame move
and advanced contractors have a very
good relationship with the country
but you don't know that and they have
spikes look here germany low yeah nine
thousand
here's one right here united states you
take the number of cases okay look
we're last meaning we're first lost i
don't know what we're facing we're last
meaning we're first we're the best
as a whole again it's cases okay
um and we have cases i mean they're
fantastic
a thousand americans die today but i
understand i understand all cases
it's different no but you're not
reporting it correctly jonathan
i think i am but can you take a look at
this other chart
look this is our testing i believe this
is the testing yeah
yeah we do more tests now wait a minute
well don't we get credit for that
and because we do more tests we have
more cases in other words
we test so it's funny again so now trump
has shifted to instead of arguing about
the case about the death rate he's
talking about cases but at the same time
he wants to use the cases as a framework
for talking about deaths yet he says
cases don't really matter because we
just test a lot like
if you're confused by what i'm saying
it's because it's confusing
well we have now take a look the top one
that's a good thing not a bad thing
at the top jonathan if if if hospital
rates were going down and deaths were
going down i'd say terrific
you deserve to be praised for testing
but they're all going in are they very
possibly sixty thousand americans are in
hospital you watch thousands
read the papers they usually talk about
new cases new cases new cases
i'm talking about death will you look
it's good enough death is way down from
where it was it's
a thousand a day it was two that half
thousand it went down to five hundred
now it's going up again
excuse me where it was is much higher
than where it is right now it went down
but now it's going down again it's going
down in arizona it's going down
of you it's going down in texas take a
look at this
these are the it seems like a comedy
sketch like with the calculated zoom ins
on the
on the pieces of paper you couldn't edit
it in a more satirical way but it's real
yes it's going down in florida yeah it's
going it leveled out and it's going down
that's my report as of yesterday
yesterday yeah so anyway very very bad i
mean it's crazy what's going on
um couple other things i came across
this parody this is appears to be a
parody account
of me this is the profile picture
this is the banner picture when i had
dinner with
hassan destiny [ __ ] the second stephen
kenneth destiny bonnell ii
and molina gorenson a lot of the posts
are like clips of me let's see what they
are
the david pakman show giving jews a bad
name since 1984
and hispanics oh my god that's not good
and let's see here
he in the deep end for so long before
the current
um brings you close to the p even if
you're in the shallow
you can only wow that's from yesterday
oh yeah
i was sent this meme so what is this
this is
this is um chad pacman versus
virgin destiny okay so why yes we will
be reviewing today's press briefing
starts bright and early does not block
destiny ooc
eats a singular strawberry he grew
himself response to every
sub and donor on three platforms that's
true uh let's talk about recent
political events okay
destiny starts an hour late is that true
insults donors
conservative video review maybe opens
league
had his friend block destiny allowed
hassan to dominate political content on
twitch eats only soylent and cereal i
don't know if any of this stuff is true
honestly
but it's interesting i don't even know i
guess it's
is so is this what we would call a
parody account is this what the kids
would call a parody account that's weird
but certainly interesting nonetheless
and then so that's this one i also got
this
so yesterday let me see if i can zoom
this out hold on a second there we go
yesterday i was asked via youtube super
chat whether i eat
mac and cheese with a fork or a spoon
and i said obviously i eat it with a
fork
i use spoons for soups and desserts and
i guess that was controversial in some
circles and then now
somebody photo photoshopped my face with
a crazy hairstyle onto trump's
body eating a bucket of kfc chicken and
yes i am holding a knife and fork i
don't really need the knife
for mac and cheese but needless to say
i do use a fork for mac and cheese so if
you have any similar images or memes or
anything you want to send
you can send them to me david
davidpakman.com
is the place to do it um
what else uh oh trajectory for a million
subscribers we did get another day
closer
so when we hit 900 000 subscribers on
youtube last week i said my goal is a
million by election day
we were originally targeting it looked
like we were on track for
january 9 thanks to your support
we are now on track for december 25th
to hit a million and we are only we only
need to push that up by
six weeks in order to hit it by election
day
so very much appreciate everybody who
has been signing up
let's look at a few super chats i do
have some clips from yesterday's uh
live stream or live stream as some call
it with the
grip chess grandmaster hikaru nakamura
which i'll be publishing to my youtube
channel in total
but i'll get to that in a bit stuart
keating asks do you think
wallace and john swann are doing tough
interviews because of trump
because they think he will not be in
office soon nothing lost more to gain
it's certainly conceivable certainly
conceivable and again they only look
like they're playing hardball because
everybody else plays softball it's
important to keep that in mind
in many other countries every interview
every interview of a president
would be uh this tough and that's uh
that's something important to keep in
mind
jen o fire says david your feed keeps
cutting out
everything's fine on my end so it could
be um could be a youtube thing but
everything
everything's fine over here emmanuel
kant says i'm still recovering from
yesterday's plasma party yeah me too
baconlover says youtube is booting
people from your stream
well we don't want that unknown prodigy
says good job with the opposition way to
move that king and pawn
yeah so here was a crucial moment from
yesterday's stream with hikaru nakamura
this was actually a huge win in the
battle of the churning
of the satang of the baking of ideas
take a listen to this
category yes steve stephen kenneth
destiny bonnell ii would be an
interesting player
in the tournament uh yeah i mean you i
like i feel like your
politics and the way you explain things
is a little bit better honestly like
really oh my god
clip that jeez holy [ __ ] we've gotta
clip that thing
that's shocking okay so
as people can see very very funny stuff
i actually should see whether other
people clipped
and cheering for right oh my god hold on
a second um
videos i want to see clips that people
did how can i see
user generated clips um
clips okay and then
i want 24 hours
oh i don't know that i'm actually in any
of these well let's see let's just see
what somebody clipped from my uh
appearance yesterday let's see
yeah steve stephen kenneth destiny
that's the one i just played obviously
uh here's another one let's see what
this one is
tend to look at it from that standpoint
of like if
you're not good at chess you're you know
you're you're still
all right well this is not going as well
as i thought so we'll go back to the mac
and annie
feed because who knows what is going on
let me say a huge thank you to keep
roland rolando who has supported over on
twitch brown
albino is a new twitch prime subscriber
also noogie13 has subscribed with prime
now i'm getting messages that the audio
and video are unsynced
on youtube something's going on with
youtube i have no control over it
my my feed is fine the same feed is
going to twitch and facebook
so if there's a problem over on youtube
uh it is indeed
because of something happening on
youtube i have no control over it
axis audio says hey david your stream
isn't working for me
okay um
[Music]
well let's see jerry lou rice says it
looks like from the comments that my
screen and a few others are going black
quickly after the stream loads okay
um i don't think i can do anything about
it
g says hey david thank you for fighting
the good fight against the ministry of
truth
charlie says feed cutting out for me too
have to keep refreshing
paul milbank says david it's cutting out
for a lot of people
i don't know if people understand i
can't do anything about it
but the first thing you should do is hit
f5 and refresh that would be just step
one
in order to see if you can get resynced
sometimes these brief
feed issues will resolve after
refreshing
haywood jablom
guys i know the bill o'reilly thing
actually let's find that that's that's
that's a top clip that's a top clip uh
let me see here
bill o'reilly
haywood jablom as bill o'reilly
pronounces it um
oh god that's just the best clip it's a
great reference so i'm actually going to
look for it
bill o'reilly
haywood uh
i can't find it unfortunately i'm unable
to find it but it's it's a truly classic
classic clip anyway the question is dave
do you acknowledge your immense
privilege from receiving training from
world-class chess players before your
tournament a bit unfair huh
that's the entire everybody gets
training i mean everybody
that's that's the idea the idea of the
tournament is all the participants
get trained by really great players
thanks to a political puppy for
subscribing for eight months at tier one
says i'm glad to hear you're doing
things with the serfs soon yes indeed
adjective pants says hey david i know
you said you're going electric for your
next car have you decided what you're
getting yet oh my god i already have it
and it is a it's a widely kept trade
secret
so i'm unable to say more about it um we
are in the middle of a level two hype
train
as well which i do want to remind people
of
edgar garcia says nothing says
nothing okay ahmer nail says hi from
austria two-thirds of americans oppose
trump if he wins the election then
democrats progressives and liberals have
only themselves to blame
please vote please vote stuart keating
says have you been winning more chess
games than before
no in fact the more training i get the
more chess games i lose it's
it's really embarrassing but i'm losing
more chess games than ever which is
crazy
let me say thank you to luis manuel
da silva mederos pereira wow
that is uh that is a mouthful who is new
member number
one today at joinpakman.com
um also see one other thing here
uh okay no that's working correctly
perfect
okay good zest the african says
favorite political philosopher i'm
really loving kant and
franz fanon may seem contradictory lol
i don't really have a favorite
philosopher
i've certainly read kant i've read
you know um hobbes i've i've read a lot
and
i favorite is not really a term that i
would apply
personally from the standpoint of
personal
gen o fire says hey all if you're using
mobile try an
internet browser google chrome instead
of the youtube app that's interesting if
people are all having a problem
with the youtube app i'm viewing the
feed on
browser desktop browser so maybe that's
why i'm not having a problem
uh yesterday we did achieve for people
reminding me we did achieve a level 5
hype train yesterday that is true but it
was not a record-setting one
the record hype train has been six
hundred and twenty percent level five i
think yesterday we got to about a
hundred and twenty percent
um but listen forget about level five
let's just make it to level three before
we go crazy
jacob ratner says how do you convince
people that covet and the economy are
connected
if people don't understand that i don't
i mean
that has to be someone who's very
cognitively compromised not to
understand that
i tried to convince a friend we won't
recover till we fix covet and he didn't
buy
it yeah i mean it sounds like your
friend may be beyond reach
pair tier end says f5 worked perfectly
frankie g says it's not your fault bro
it can be the weather if you're on the
east coast like me so i don't know
anubis doe says we can file taxes online
why not vote online
not an unreasonable question
um we have now reached a level three
hype train
as we wait for kaylie mceneney
i also want to say thanks to leonard
arreola
who is new member number two
at joinpakman.com i think we had about
60 new members during yesterday's live
stream
which was uh crazy
crazy stuart keating says apparently
president
okay yeah we're not doing it we're not
doing it
almost got me there that reminds me
actually of
uh hold on a second but i if i was able
to better pull up
some of these clips my stream would just
be so much better
hold on a second let me see
there is a really funny one um
man i can't find it now
there's a particular clip oh it's a
local news
you know what i'll just play the audio
of it you know what i'm not even going
to do it it might actually be a little
bit racist so i'm going to skip it all
together
i just realized it's a bad direction to
go down tim ellis says just refresh i'm
sure youtube
intentionally throttles stream quality
so you have to refresh and watch another
ad
it's never happened before so i don't
know about that
uh chris r says mobile doesn't work but
desktop works fine live so maybe the
youtube problem is mobile
ryan anderson says hey david are you
familiar with owen jones uk yeah he
follows me but i don't really know much
about him to be perfectly frank
i know very little about him edgar
garcia says enjoy the show did you see
that mexico announced that schools will
stay closed and classes will be
transmitted
via over-the-air tv and radio i did not
see that
i did not see that tristan mccoppen says
everyone seems to be quoting covid 19
numbers all over seemingly unaware that
numbers are largely tampered with what
do you think
yeah i'm unclear on whether we can trust
the numbers at this point so
what since july 16th i've been going
forward
by saying these main these numbers may
not even be right
if they are right here is what the
assessment is and they may not even be
correct
thank you to a bunch of people on twitch
um cashfield has subscribed with prime
hampelman has subscribed with prime
fifi boy has subscribed with prime
oak 84 says greetings from sweden case
is dropping tremendously over here
sweden's having uh their fair share of
problems when you look at that death
rate i should say
um stuart keating says loved the coleman
hughes
interview great work yeah i got some
positive feedback about the coleman
hughes interview
and a lot of people who said they found
it extremely boring
you know we we have a mix of stuff on
the youtube channel
we are very very close to and have
actually now reached a level
four hype train thanks to zanz
the gift of a subscription by political
puppy
grant land and old man marr
all of whom have subscribed and we are
now in the middle of a level
four hype train as daniel cardosa has
become
new member number three at
joinedpakman.com
uh mike okay all right i
mike says how many show shirts do you
own not much rotation
i think i have a rotation of about 20
shirts for the show
captain ako says do republicans secretly
dislike trump
some do could the republicans be
allowing trump to do more interviews as
a way to sabotage it's not republicans
that are allowing trump to do interviews
it's trump
you know trump's own staff can't control
him and he's doing whatever
whatever he wants thanks to floydo
59 for subscribing with twitch prime as
we stand by waiting for
a panicked press briefing from kaylee
mceneny
if you were just joining um we
anticipate that she will be somewhere
between 10 and 30 minutes late
which tends to be the trend um
and there is a potential chess stream
tonight i've been going back and forth
with alexandra botez about when my next
training is going to be
it maybe tonight it may not we're still
trying to figure it out thanks to bib
big milk 13. for subscribing with twitch
prime uh i did people asking for memes i
already showed a couple
earlier today um let's see
i guess i i will just show you one do i
have anything else
no this the the big one that i got was
in response to my claim yesterday
my claim my explanation that i eat mac
and cheese with a fork
somebody made this it's kind of funny
you can send your memes to me
david davidpakman.com or post them to
the david pakman show
subreddit and they may end up on a live
stream
uh so those are those are good the memes
are definitely i feel like as we're
getting closer and closer to the
election it may just be a function of
growing our following on twitch but
the memes are accelerating for sure troy
baker asks do you think the threat of
ecological collapse should give us pause
when planning kids
i i think it's reasonable to think about
that i got a call
a couple years ago from an a so-called
anti-natalist
and uh i think it's reasonable to be
thinking about that
but you know how far you take that
depends on your perspective
i mean listen long term unless we get to
some other planet
the sun will expand and engulf the earth
and everybody's dead
so you don't even need to think about
ecological collapse if you really want
to go
to the full end of that
sort of you know nihilism but
you know maybe by then we'll be off the
planet
anthony malecki asks chances kushner
goes to jail in the future
very low stuart keating says if you want
a million subs before the election
sell out and make a why i left the left
video
go on prageru get a show on blase tv
success yeah i mean listen there's a
cheap way
to dramatically accelerate my following
which is to have some political
awakening where i
find truth and see the light and
denounce everything
right we're not gonna do that okay if
i can't get to a million subscribers
based on
doing what i actually believe wink wink
um then i'm not gonna get to a million
subscribers and that's it
that's it i'm churning ideas here i'm
french pressing ideas
i am uh you know extracting ideas very
powerfully like an espresso machine
uh i'm sauteing ideas and all of these
other things
uh so and and they are going to be my
ideas i'm not going to do
you know we know about grifting we know
about grifting very powerfully
i'm hydraulically pressing ideas and um
you know dremeling ideas and all of this
stuff all the time
okay clinky winky oh wait no i skipped
one
jackson says i completely agree with
your stance on mac and cheese with a
fork
but i must object to eating desserts
such as cakes or tiramisu with a spoon
sad
cake i admit i sometimes will violate my
spoon for dessert
protocol i have in the past eaten cake
with a fork but tiramisu i go spoon
spoon all the way big thank you to diana
weingarte and peter blair who were new
members four and five today at
jointpakman.com thanks very much guys i
appreciate that
we are standing by for kaylee mcinanni
scheduled for seven minutes ago and so
far running late
a big appreciation to do sydney
for subscribing with twitch prime
gyratory
as well has subscribed with prime we
have three and a half minutes
to complete a level 5 hype train to
bring it to full completion
three and a half minutes we are at 13
percent
right now clinky winky says have you
seen
the fox news corona chart where the
colors are inverted like less impacted
states where red hard hit states are
green what are your thoughts
that's straight out of how to lie with
statistics yeah i haven't seen that
but it is interesting and i plan to uh
take a look at that that's wild
thanks to professor faith and baker full
for subscribing on twitch juan castillo
says como estado fue un dolar cetera
says looking pretty sharp today david is
that shirt from seville roe yeah exactly
exactly i don't even know what that is
but sure funky slurts says i feel like
america would have been
invaded by america if it was in the
middle east in the name of democracy
absolutely oh my goodness absolutely
completely
brad lures has subscribed on youtube
janelle says what's going on with the
youtube stream it keeps cutting off yeah
we are receiving very detailed reports
that the youtube mobile app is not
working well
youtube mobile browser and desktop
browser
are reportedly working perfectly
so something to think about dranoa has
just gifted
five community subscriptions and has
exploded to the completion of a level
five
hype train we are now at where are we
we are now at i've got an animation
playing
113 with 90 seconds to go
our record is 620 is it possible
is it possible 200 percent
uh crazy things are happening truth
seeker
oh wait hold on a second
israel mckenzie says bi-metal sports you
heathens
i don't even know what that means wilma
fist
fit says why don't you wear a sports
coat anymore you lack panache
uh you know i decided that at this point
independent media has really taken on an
identity of its own
and i decided that the sports coat
was almost um out of sync
with the vibe of the show so i made the
decision some months ago
to drop the sports coat i did and
i don't really need sports coats anymore
because i don't go anywhere because of
the virus
so at some point maybe i'll get rid of
them i don't know but uh
i'm i'm happy with the decision also the
rolled up sleeves is something i've
adopted recently
and i think that it just it's i think
it's a nice look i think that it does
it just it fits better with some of what
we're doing so i don't regret it
for a minute um
truthseeker2020 says hey david just saw
a video of aurora colorado police
handcuffing and ground
for african-american children 16 and
under for a falsely suspected stolen car
okay i haven't seen that story but i
will check it out
we are approaching 300 percent of a
level 5 hype train
with just 10 seconds to go i do want to
say thanks to remnant psyche
larry eldritch krusty sandwich
hampelman for cheering 5 000 bits
and getting us to 400 433 percent
of a level 5 hype train we did it ladies
and gentlemen
we did it golfer jack david please
lean into the race to a million with
majority report
it'll be good fun and will help you both
even if you're going to lose left is
best
okay trent munsinger says you're
cracking me up david thank you i needed
it today
why are people talking about majority
report whenever i talk about a million
subscriptions
like are we close let's see
majority report uh oh
909 okay and then where am i right now
on subscriptions let's see 9 11
actually we're only 100 from 9 12. if
100 people on youtube can hit that
subscribe button we'll be at 9 12. okay
so sam and i are close i didn't realize
that it was so close
i sort of just focus on myself um
but that is interesting that we are that
close i did not know that
i did not know that um okay
dan mccord says david is this press
conference again another waste of time
yes but it's an opportunity for us to be
together so that's great
unless they're giving new and useful
info they are worthless in my view
you know i'm starting to suspect that
this one could be canceled altogether
because we're not even live in the room
yet and trump has an event scheduled for
12 45
and often kaylee is at those events so
i would not be totally shocked if there
was a cancellation
see if i got any messages about that no
um so we'll see we'll see juan castillo
says kennedy for senate
diane marzany says new to the twitch
deal don't know how to support you in
the hype train guess i'm showing my age
lol
well you're supporting on youtube diane
that's much appreciated
oh did kaylee cancel is that true i see
one person saying it was cancelled axios
interview i'm discussing on the
broadcast show today so i played a clip
earlier but i don't want to do
the entire segment over again because i
am doing it later
it's live in the room with other
channels oh okay let me pull that up
maybe now this is in the room let's see
now this press briefing
okay ah yes they are live in the room
beautiful let's take a look
whoa the room is empty that is never a
good sign
that is never a good sign but we'll keep
an eye on that
israel mackenzie says autocorrect
doesn't like metal sporks
okay casey bates says real dp here
youtube app cuts out every 10 seconds
okay mike henderson says admiral gerard
explained why the numbers are down in
the south he said in the south they
reduced the testing by using
selective testing this was on meet the
press i will look for that
robert downes says i'm trying to imagine
mac and cheese that could make sense to
eat with a spoon and it's making me sad
that anyone thinks that's how it should
be
yeah you're basically talking about
pasta soup if mac and cheese should it
has to be eaten with a spoon
you're talking about pasta soup
essentially that's a different dish
cecilia girasso says annoyed by the fact
that the so-called leader of the free
world
also impact my life indeed in denmark
and i have no say in the election scary
i feel for you
feel for you um
robert mifflin says beirut has been
attacked
let's let's look that up um
beirut massive explosion rocks beirut
see what's going on
um at the port
okay it's still very early i don't think
we could reasonably add anything to
what's going on right now
so it sounds bad and i'm i i don't like
hearing that but we're going to give
that a little bit of time
thanks to robert bates rostin who's new
member number six today at
joinedpakman.com brendan martin
is new member number seven today jason
gehen
is number eight today um
and i think that gets us caught up with
members at joinedpakman.com
captain crunch says hey david if biden's
vp came down to susan rice or kamala who
would you prefer and why
um that's a good question i mean i think
kamal is problematic because of her role
as attorney general in california
and and um i i
there at one point black voters actually
preferred warren to kamala
susan rice i don't know enough about
susan rice to say but there's definitely
question marks
around kamala harris if it's warren
kamala or susan rice
obviously i'm voting for joe biden no
doubt about that
but it's a fair question blake feely
says aurora colorado
video of the children being arrested and
held at gunpoint is horrifying it sounds
it i'm gonna look for that christopher
gilliam says do your next broadcast in
boxers and a
woof beater david that's what the people
want
lars testerman says deepak looking like
a snack
okay beetle greg says david for
president
i uh i am a foreigner so i cannot be a
president here
and cooley man says how many presidents
does it take to screw
a light bulb fair question
fair question i also wonder why
the lighting has to be changed so
regularly
is it that there's the trump lighting
and the cayley lighting is that maybe
the idea but you'd think that they'd
have it all set up in a way where they
can just
flip a switch rather than have to
physically move lights every time it's
kind of weird
lou bittup says would you dance on cameo
if a powerful tip was offered i don't
know
that doesn't sound that fun i am on
cameo and i've gotten
how many cameo videos have i done let me
see here
i get some pretty funny requests on
cameo every once in a while i do have to
reject something because it's just
not good um i've done okay so a little
over 50 requests on cameo i've done
i don't know listen here's what i say
send the request and then i'll evaluate
it
thanks to alex endicott for signing up
at the soyboy level walla is me says
went to my third black lives matter
protest in la mesa california
police in full riot gear with batons out
trumpists antagonizing us one guy
lowered his shoulder into me
another one got arrested surreal
vigilante groups claim
credit for peace right
the vegan villainess says desantis in
florida stopped testing last wednesday
way ahead of the storm
they are already saying that cases are
going down without mentioning this yeah
someone mentioned that earlier i'm going
to research that if true that is
despicable
despite myself has signed up at the
soyboy level mark
chu says what cabinet position would you
like to see andrew yang take in biden's
administration i have no idea i don't
know that andrew yang
is going to be in joe biden's uh cabinet
but it is certainly an interesting idea
nonetheless thanks to jericho who has
subscribed over on twitch we are just
three twitch subscribers from
a thousand which is a beautiful round
number jericho says love your coverage
of these press conferences
thanks jericho you are subscriber 997
over on twitch also thank you to havoc
dog
who was subscriber 996
and i think i'm caught up
from the standpoint of twitch
you have not missed anything you might
be wondering
this was supposed to start 20 minutes
ago how is it that we're not seeing
anything yet
it's because they must be running
historically late
and um donald trump has an event on an
event he's having lunch at 12 45
and typically kaylee would be done
by that point so i don't know what's
going on but as usual i am
just as much subject to the whims of the
lateness
of kaylee mckennany we all are
and looks like we've got a couple more
reporters in the room
but it is very very slow what is
happening today
robert fancy pants motorcycle mcgee
sends a hundred argentinian peso
super chat saying hey david greetings
from buenos aires
remember that's where i was born did you
enjoy trump's interview with axios yes
and we have like a 20-minute clip it's
like the zapruder film
uh publishing at 4pm today thanks to g
sound for gifting three subscriptions
and thanks to jimmy the rabbit as well
as
aquam lunet and randy sargent as well as
is biz we have now surpassed a thousand
subscribers on twitch we are back to
over a thousand we were over a thousand
for a while
and um then we were below and then now
we're back
which is great okay
did i have other cl i do have some other
clips i could play for you
um yeah by the way if you missed it
before
let me play this if you're just joining
us this is one of my new favorite clips
this is donald trump unable to pronounce
yosemite
it really it rivals plasma listen to
this this is just wild
when they gaze upon your semites your
seminites
towering heights it sounds almost like a
mormon uh
saint or something like that yosema
heights
when they gaze upon your semites your
seminites
how is this the president ladies and
gentlemen i mean really how
how is this the president brian holliday
says
what will we say 30 years from now about
2020 in the trump presidency anyone
pretending to know
is just guessing it is very difficult to
know how history will see any of what's
going on right now
christian gaffield says nice job on
catching
michael ox small's name david
yes someone did get me last week with
michael oxhard if you understand um
but i've caught a few this week dan
mccord says
if elizabeth warren is not selected for
vp where could you see her serving with
a biden presidency and why
i would be interested in elizabeth
warren as treasury secretary i think
that would be very interesting commerce
secretary um there's a lot of positions
that would be interesting for elizabeth
warren for sure
what else um i mean listen
she would be better as secretary of
housing than ben carson
right at least she's worked in the space
that kind of relates to that rather than
just being
a neurosurgeon you know um i think
there's a lot of ideas for where
elizabeth warren could do very very well
christopher gilliam says she's busy
updating her folder of talking points
always love your perspective david yeah
i mean
my feeling is this may be later than
ever this may be the latest
ever that we will see a press briefing
thanks to anonymous gifter who has
gifted a subscription to hillary clinton
beautiful i'm sure hillary will
appreciate that
very much so um it
people asking if trump's doing a 5 p.m
presser today
it is not yet on his calendar the only
things on trump's calendar
were a signing ceremony at 10 30 a.m
lunch with pompeo at 12 45
and then 2 p.m intelligence briefing
so uh you know we we will see
we will see unknown prodigy says
do you know amanda huggin kiss i do i
know ben dover as well
ben and amanda are great people they
went to my school actually really really
nice
addison adset metz says hey david keep
up the good work
i think kamala should be attorney
general warren should be treasury
secretary
kamala was a disastrous attorney general
in california i don't know why you would
make her attorney general of the united
states that to me is dubious very very
dubious
i don't know what people in the chat
think but that seems like a bad idea
people seem to be aware
yeah okay people seem to agree
love it love it love it love it okay
good all right reporters are starting to
file in now which is a good thing
um i would like to take just 30 seconds
to make a hard sell membership pitch to
you i've been reducing these and people
seem to
be responding we do have this program
where we have employees employees you
know we we contribute to health
insurance for employees
we're starting up a retirement plan we
uh offer
good work conditions and all of this
stuff everything we do podcast tv show
radio shows streams
all that stuff funded by membership on
my website joinpakman.com the website
has recently been upgraded to be
able to handle all the traffic you can
throw at it which we needed to do
and if you at all have any interest in
supporting what i do
you can sign up at joinpakman.com now if
you hate me
if you're an anti-semite if you don't
like hispanic people
if you ever use the word libtard this
probably is not
the the thing for you to support and
that's fine
um but if you do appreciate the work
that we do
and you have an extra dollar eighty or
two bucks a month you can go to
joinpakman.com that coupon code above my
head
2020 now it just chops it's just like
chop it
66 off of the price two bucks a month
or if you pay for the entire year it's a
dollar eighty-three
one this is u.s dollars by the way and
do the prices
ever go up the answer is of course they
do not
the price never goes up this is not some
late night tv
low low introductory price which then
balloons
in a month once you get the low price it
is yours for
as long as you want to keep it we do
have a handful of members
who have been members for 10 years if
you can imagine that i was in preschool
when these folks signed up and it was a
beautiful beautiful thing so
consider getting yourself a membership
and i will thank you if you do
one such example is nick childress who
just signed up in his new member number
nine today nick
thank you so much for your support nick
taking advantage
of the 2020 now coupon code i love it i
just absolutely love it
okay other super chats coming in
where did i leave off gregory sico
celebrated obama's birthday by voting in
my state's primary
very nice yeah it is obama's birthday
today drew goo
says you should do a media share stream
i don't even know what that means what
can somebody explain to me what a media
share stream is is that just where i
play clips and comment on them
anybody know
nobody knows okay media share
yes you guys share clips
okay well seems straightforward it's
kind of what we're doing right now right
i mean we're watching video
unknown prodigy says seriously do you
think you have a chance to win pog
champs i think you were going to win
i don't think so i mean listen the more
training i get i've now had lessons with
international master levy rosman
uh international master eric rosen
i don't know what alex botez's title is
is she a women's feed master
alex botez and giga grand master
hikaru nakamura i'm losing more
games than ever so i don't know i really
don't know
um jonas kahl says hey david hope you
the team and the family are we
well many hugs from tallinn love it i i
had such a great time
in tallinn where did that go uh let me
pull up a map actually
let me see here map step tallinn was i i
actually had some
uh david pakman show viewers run into me
in tallinn estonia which was amazing let
me pull up a map and see if i can figure
out where that was
i was in tallinn last uh
i don't even know when it was it was a
little while ago so let's see here
this is the center of tallinn we stayed
somewhere right around this area sort of
right around here
and there oh wait no no no i went to
this this was a great restaurant right
here
rata skavu 16. tremendous restaurant in
tallinn and i think i stayed right
around this corner here i remember there
was a little corner store here yep here
it is
and some great views now there was this
kind of brooklyn-like area
which i think was like over here
maybe it's this maybe not in any case it
was like a
food stall area and some american
viewers who were traveling through
europe uh came up and said hello and it
was great
it was great none of this is sponsored
these are just places i like
oh okay uh cameo requests are coming in
i'm gonna mute my phone for the time
being uh danny thompson says
i want to see a black woman as education
secretary so we can concentrate on
getting rid of whitewashed textbooks
that's an interesting idea
richard laram has subscribed at the
soyboy level
chad lightning says top three favorite
bands or artists right now oh i listened
to so much music i couldn't possibly
name
three um but i'm listening to a lot of
argentinian music
a lot of argentinian music cooley man
says there's footage of the beirut
explosion and it is shocking by its
scale it was 20 minutes ago i i plan to
look at it after the stream i just don't
want to pull up any any unpredictable
stuff on stream
chakuseki says dear david have you had
to ban hammer
any yantai anti yosema heights
today um not yet
not yet yeah if you don't know the
reference this is the president folks
when they gaze upon your semites
yosemites
towering sequoias
yosemites nothing better than that
looks like we are getting close to the
start of this press
briefing i have some beautiful and
lovely people to thank
patrick evans is new member number 10
today on my website
cameron johnson is new member number 11.
adam donnells is new member number 12.
anthony spurgeon is new member number
13.
jesse morales is number 14 also can't
forget nicholas bova
who is new member number 15 today lastly
john
capizzoli is new member number 16.
oh what am i talking about not lastly
matt flickinger
is number 17. juan
bajorquez is number 18.
elijah kelly is number 19 wow that bar
is filling up
christian ciswick is new member number
20
and uh jake carter is new member number
21. now i
am caught up now i am caught up am i
yes i am caught up also thanks over on
twitch to
frosty snowman nato jenkins
as well as anonymous gifter who has
gifted a subscription to donald trump's
tiny hands
also big thank you to agent b 64
agent b64 let's see
watching naked asks whether i would ever
go vegan
i don't see myself going vegan no
um continued complaints about the
youtube live stream crashing
yeah i can't control it it's a youtube
problem it's not uh it's not on my end
addison adset's mets says i guess kamala
does suck
ike jew says uh has subscribed as a soy
boy
whoops i missed a few there
tate dalzell says if the u.s continues
its descent into idiocracy
where would emigrate to if you had a
choice and weren't a refugee that wasn't
given that agency
i have a clip i published on friday
about that
um you know the places i could go are
argentina and israel but i'm still
working on getting my polish citizenship
so that i could have an eu passport
eduardo lino costa
says have you ever considered a live
audience show yes
kind of moot now in fact i was i was um
50 yeah i was 60 of the way to a
national tour
along with a prominent female
progressive host
where we were going to do 10 or 12 live
in person events
around the country with audiences of
about
three to four hundred at each event and
of course then
coronavirus coronavirus
joseph josepha silva says thoughts on
the obama's views on young voters not
being informed enough on government
dealings and inner working
i have not seen that said i don't know
exactly what he said
so i would not be able to comment
offhand captain crunch says correct me
if i'm wrong david but i believe trump
meant to say
yo semites lechayam maybe that's what
let me see is that what trump meant to
say
when they gaze upon your semites your
seminites
yeah maybe that's what trump meant
that's that's certainly possible
norwegian trad archer says you are way
off with your sonde
versus picture yes there's a youtube
issue please refresh
please refresh we have no control over
it
refreshing seems to mostly fix it and if
it happens again you gotta fix it again
thank you to spudnik for both
subscribing
and gifting five subscriptions it feels
like we're getting close to the start of
this press briefing
um something weird is going on though
now i there's actually a couple issues
with the youtube feed which are odd
certainly which i'm going to try to fix
uh
okay i think i think we just fixed a few
different elements
extreme tuber says holy crap for them to
be this late they must be in
super damage control mode robert clobber
oh let me see if the white house feed is
even live yet
still not live this usually goes live
shortly beforehand
so that's weird uh robert klobber says
hope i'm not too late to the party with
this but man that axios trump interview
is massively concerning yeah i've got a
20-minute clip with detailed
i analyzed it like the zapruder film and
we're going to
publish that clip in a couple of hours
cajun girl says serious question
what is the great american outdoor act i
have no idea
fonique the second i'm not anti-semite
but i
am anti-yosemite that's fair that's fair
adam dunnell says hey david i've been a
fan since 14
just signed up with the coupon code love
it
yeah a few other people who just used
the coupon code to sign up
uriel carresti is number 22.
dan sylvester is new member number 23.
adli teague is new member number 24.
laurie moore is new member 25 let's go
for 50 my friends why not
uh cindy pifer is new member number 26.
i could have sworn cindy signed up
yesterday
oh no cindy cancelled oh my god i've got
to go back to 25 how embarrassing
uh oh boy brian boyak is actually number
26 today
joseph barter stephen scales
estrella rios and douglas steckel are
numbers 27
28 29 and 30.
steckle reminds me of that infamous
seinfeld episode
where i believe it's brian cranston in a
little-known role
uh converts to judaism
and makes jewish jokes and uses
vernacular
like asking his dental assistant for a
stickle of fluoride that's a classic
classic episode
nancy lindsay and sheila brown are new
members number 31 and 32
and i think that that gets me where i
need to be which is completely caught up
yeah the anti-dentite
seinfeld episode that entire arc is uh
it's genius it's absolute complete
genius
okay ms smith says thanks for keeping us
sane hello from the uk
hello love the uk alex endicott says
odds that they called this conference to
whine about democrats
very likely very very likely jorgen asks
says love your show time to get that
five-year-old out of the white house you
should play against magnus carlsen
greetings from norway
i think if i took two more lessons with
hikaru i could probably
hold my own against magnus yeah just
kidding i'm not an idiot
roy m has subscribed at the soyboy level
where'd that go there it is
miguel palacio says soda so i'm more of
a soda stereo guy myself
addison adsen met says hey david biden
actually has some good policy ideas yeah
i've covered them
but mainstream media usually only
focuses on superficial policy debates
does this hurt biden yeah i i've you
know
i've looked at biden's climate plan
biden's tax plan
biden's green energy plan uh and they
are
they are reasonable plans they very much
so
joe rogan's left testicle has subscribed
with twitch prime
kamryk has subscribed as well with the
message
youtube stream not working twitch is
where it's at today
sam karim says why does trump brag about
the early china travel ban shouldn't
that show how badly he's botched
everything even after doing the ban
early
absolutely very good point eraser says
you would great polish citizen did you
visit poland no i've not visited poland
but
because my grandfather was born in
poland and fled
before world war ii i qualify
for uh polish citizenship if
i can find his birth certificate and the
problem we're having and maybe there's
someone either in poland or belarus who
could help me with this
the part of poland my grandfather was
born in
is now belarus and there are not
diplomatic relations between poland and
belarus
so when i've talked to lawyers in poland
who can assist
with these citizenship procedures
they say we can't really do anything
with belarus you'd have to figure out if
you can find the birth certificate in
belarus
so i um if anybody knows of an agency
in belarus that specializes in finding
documents
in the areas that were poland 50 years
ago or longer
then let me know yeah and by the way i'm
not looking to go live in poland but
having an eu passport would be very very
valuable right now
thanks to brian the lady for signing up
with twitch prime
cynical insomniac has signed up and says
honestly cannot watch this dribble
dribble without your humor and
interjections thank you
thank you i wouldn't be doing it if you
weren't here
um what else do we have going on
tony spurgan says why did you call this
panicked
it's just a meme now like each day i i
just will
use different adjectives to describe
these uh
events christian gaffield says elizabeth
warren for education secretary she
started out as a teacher
listen warren would be a reasonable
treasury secretary education secretary
commerce secretary it's a it's a long
list
it's a long list ajc
21086 as well as carol ann smith have
grabbed youtube memberships
brett kanter says explosion in lebanon
might be the cause of the delay
actually that could be lance powers raul
martinez have signed up tanner stark he
says opinion on philip mccrevice
sending word i i'm sorry i don't know
what that means
jake feldman says david how have you not
pulled out all that immaculate hair
thanks for being here in this hell pit
of history
yeah i don't know it's it's not good
it's not good
my hair does seem to be more under
control lately though strangely
whoa actually this is this is weird oh
my god
that's weird i could be in all american
rejects with this band over this hair
right
anyway we'll get it oh my god now it's
out of control
all right well this we are now thinking
this is going to start pretty soon
uh big thank you to linda knapp who's
new member number 33 today at
joinedpakman.com
also uh oh cindy pifer is back cindy
didn't cancel she upgraded
her membership i love it thank you cindy
lauren kimball is new member number 35.
lori shinsato is new member number 36.
jody saint amore is number 37.
stefan sonic de a
i don't even know if i got that right is
number 38
and kathy campbell is number 39 and i
don't want to forget about sebastian
guri and lance powers who are numbers 40
and 41 wow
that website can barely take the heat
the camera are now shaking
and i believe we are very very close to
the start of this press briefing
i let whoa these are some strange angles
i'm going to mention this just once we
are in a race to 1 million
subscribers on our youtube channel
7 200 people watching right now
please hit that subscribe button if you
are not yet subscribed we have just
reached 912
000 putting us only 88 000 away
from a million eight thousand away it's
free
it is completely and totally free uh and
very much appreciated
let's see if the white house feed has
gone live it has okay good
so let's mute here beautiful
this is our preferred stream and we have
some live sound going so it should be
starting very very soon
stranger danger says hi david it's me
michael a stranger okay
kristen hernandez says are you still
going to try a spanish pacman show
no probably not we decided it really it
just doesn't make sense i'm too busy as
it is
i need to reduce my workload by about 30
percent
so at this point i'm not going to add
new things
thank you to klim nim and jean o'fire
for subscribing and upgrading on youtube
be crow says get a haircut you freaking
hippie
kurt wells says the snack food content
the other day was delightful
yeah i don't know what you mean i do
have a picture on my instagram
of a bunch of uh argentinian
foods that have uh been purchased and
made for me
oh on uh pampa direct i see what you're
saying
let's see here um
okay hourglass 420 has signed up
anthony sanchez says thank you david for
all that you do
paula chaikin has subscribed at the
soyboy level
jackson says why did republicans
politicize masks and hydroxy seems like
a losing strategy if trump crushed
corona he sails into reelection
i've said that since day one absolutely
thanks to mel for upgrading the
membership felipe segura
sends a super chat brian fleming says
our country is going downhill fast
and all i have left is sarcasm keep
fighting the good fight
what do you think about a postponed
election i do not believe the election
is getting postponed
period l mcvicar says youtube feed is
junk please don't make me watch now news
all right i want to say thanks to
dank vader oh my god a superhero dank
vader
has subscribed and is number 42 today
also a big thank you to
uh wait a second i want to make sure i
use this person's
not real name because they want to use a
handle
actually i'll wait on that yeah we're
going to wait on that okay
and thanks to christy for signing up on
youtube at the soyboy
level over on twitch grievous quintuple
11 has grabbed the twitch prime
subscription
staple face zero jeffrey is steven
and tashi jane have subscribed on twitch
what are we expecting today in terms of
how long kaylee will speak
before going to questions is it going to
be 45 seconds 60 seconds 90 seconds
a full five minutes what do people think
she's been going very quickly to
questions recently
69 seconds yes that's very very clever
yeah i think it's going to be a couple
minutes i don't think it'll be more than
that
there's very limited material recently
30 seconds
minutes because of beirut that's fair
she may have more to say
uh because of what's going on in beirut
that could be
addison adset's adsit mets says everyone
on the left needs to watch your segment
on useless irrelevant infighting on the
left it is brilliant
and we must all come together thank you
user says belarus specialist bald and
bankrupt youtube
i've seen that channel before anthony
gonzalez has signed up on youtube so has
chris
fitzgerald which i very much appreciate
it
gagex bro has subscribed on twitch okay
now people are saying that there may
actually be a formal delay it's like
it's already been 45 minutes
yeah i don't know i really don't know
does anybody i don't know that they've
ever been this late
this is very very late
felipe segura says where is gary
johnson's votes going this election he
took a bunch of votes
last election i think it'll be split
between trump
and uh biden tucker nixon says thanks
david for all your great knowledge
thank you
we are delayed people claiming there is
a delay
yeah i i you know i know people are just
messing with me i'm not sure
it's completely reasonable that there's
a delay and there it's conceivable that
it's because of what's happening in
beirut
um and if that's the case this may be
cancelled altogether
let's say i guess now that it's been a
little longer
let's see what is being reported
currently from beirut we will pull up an
article
[Music]
lebanese capital rocked by huge
explosion
lebanese hospitals told to prepare for
casualties lebanon's health minister
hamad hassan has ordered all hospitals
to prepare to receive those injured in a
major blast in beirut
explosion has caused a large number of
injuries oh my god
lebanese authorities say an explosion
near beirut's port on tuesday evening
has left a large number of people
injured the explosion caused massive
damage to the surrounding area sent a
huge cloud of red smoke over the city
lebanon state-run nna reports that a
major fire broke out near beirut port
and firefighting teams
have rushed to the scene to put out the
fire the lebanese red cross is calling
on medics to mobilize immediately and
report to their respective centers
to help deal with the massive explosion
that rock bay route poured on tuesday
evening
the apartment shook horizontally wow
homes up to 10 kilometers away were
damaged according to witnesses
one bay resident several kilometers away
said our windows were shattered by the
explosion
wow huge explosion in lebanon's capital
beirut blew out the windows of the cnn
bureau
never felt anything like it i've been
around the block and seen pretty large
explosions this was bigger
as far as i can tell this was there was
just one absolutely massive explosion
which caused all of this damage in the
capital fire broke out in a warehouse
used for storing firecrackers
oh so we still don't know about the
cause
okay yeah i mean i think we just want to
be careful since we don't yet know
um wow this is crazy how long it's taken
we
they still don't know the cause um
although others are saying
it was a terrorist attack
yeah i mean at this point i think we
have to wait
yup i i don't know i mean it's you know
anytime that there's something uh
happening live we want to be careful we
know there was an explosion that's what
we know so far
yeah i i don't i mean i'm not
comfortable saying it was a terrorist
attack
at this point um okay
other super chats coming in daniel
cardoso says hey david say hi to my
brother david listening from weslaco
texas
will biden win texas biden will not win
texas he will not win texas
reuben gonzalez says hey david thoughts
on senate republican liability
protection amendment and stimulus it's
disgusting and vile
and uh we talked about it extensively on
the bonus show was it earlier this week
or late last week
yeah it's vile dylan clutter says what
is our
where is our garden tour you should see
my cukes and zuks i now have multiple
cukes that are very
very quickly growing um it's gonna be
crazy
it's gonna be crazy in about two weeks
tyler wants to know who i think biden
should pick us as vp so on politics i
think it should be warren she's the most
progressive of the female
uh final four so to speak that are being
considered
and i i've explained the logic of it
before
not everybody agrees with me and that's
fine
lee buddy says odd question but what do
you think of the character of this press
secretary i first
personally find her really pretentious
oh yeah i find her personality
disgusting
james nicholson says jesus beirut looked
like a small
nuke going off yeah we are still
learning about what happened in beirut
we we just don't know
um the we don't have an explanation yet
we don't have the full
scope of it yet and i know a lot of
things are being alleged
if uh oak toast boy says do i want you
to send me safe
video of the explosion yeah if you want
to email it to me through the website
contact form
let me know when you've done it i can
pull it up and then we can um take a
look
together i think would be the way to do
it
we are still standing by for a press
briefing which has now been delayed
51 minutes 51 minutes
presumably presumably because of what's
going
on in beirut but
uh we don't know we don't know for sure
let's see i'm getting safe video sent to
me i'm told
christina says david what is your take
on dr barbet's resignation from the
health department due to a clash with
mayor de blasio
i don't know uh i don't know about that
i don't know about new york city level
stuff to that degree
um so i would not be able to comment on
that
there was a big explosion in beirut at a
fireworks factory for people who were
just joining us
we still do not know the cause
i am standing by for some safe video
thanks to ruben gonzalez for grabbing a
soy boy
level membership on youtube safe
explosion video okay
i'm going to first look at this myself
just to see if it's safe
oh my god this looks like it couldn't
possibly be real oh my god
i'm not saying it's not real it is that
actually it oh my god let me just audit
this for a second before i put it up on
screen
it actually does look like it's just a
bunch of fireworks going
off oh my god though this is insane
it's the same okay all right let's take
a look at this i've never seen anything
like this
take a look at this video
[Music]
it looks fake
oh my god okay something just started
playing from the wrong place okay i have
a video from another
angle this is truly insane
so you can see firecrackers apparently
going off
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
it looks like movie effects now people
in the chat are saying that the color of
the smoke
is indicative of what what would mostly
be
um which is caused by firecrackers
exploding
i i have never seen anything like this
that it that is
absolutely unbelievable um okay
20 people now have sent me video i think
we've i think we understand it
um that is
absolutely nuts i am not ready to say
anything about the cause but that does
seem
it does not even look real i i'm at a
loss for words it does not even look
real
it is unbelievable
okay thanks to alex eldridge william
gibbs
matthew klingensmith for signing up on
youtube as well as ruben gonzalez
although i think i already thanked ruben
um that is some of the most insane video
that i have ever seen let's just look at
this one more time because it is so
crazy
so the firecrackers seem to be going off
[Music]
and then the huge explosion happens
and so right now
this building looks okay right now right
seconds later that building looks like
it's completely destroyed it's blocks
away
unbelievable
it looks like what you think of as a
nuclear explosion
although you know i it doesn't appear to
be obviously
um wow
wow yeah i don't know i mean
we have no idea on death toll or
anything right right now um and i know
it's real i'm not saying i'm saying it
almost
looks fake but it is not actually fake
it's it's real it's insane
jerry lou rice says explosion looked
normal i was in the army first white
cloud is a supersonic shock wave like a
jet
black cloud is from carbon-based smoke
darwin harrell says i keep getting ads
for epoch times do you have any thoughts
on them
uh right-wing bomb throwers and uh of
course we have no
no uh no control over the ads that
appear on youtube
death toll i mean when it has to be high
right
how can you have an explosion this big
and the death toll is not high i mean
it's
where was that i mean look at that
that's it's just unbelievable
unbelievably tragic
um and we'll see what other information
we were able to find
thousands dead some people are saying i
don't know
bodies near the blast on videos yeah i'm
not going to play that stuff
but i would not doubt it i would not
doubt it unbelievable
um wow thanks to
floaties mcgoatys for subscribing with
prime
also dj snipes has subscribed
we are now almost a full hour late for
this press briefing
will it ever start does anybody have any
official word as to whether it's been
delayed it was scheduled for noon
eastern time we are 57 minutes
beyond that um reporters have been
sitting in the room for a very long time
at this point
justin t has subscribed over on youtube
brand x and typhoid games as well as hot
yogurt
have subscribed on twitch
darwin harrell says here's another tip
for saying my name correctly on the
first go okay thanks
uh thanks to lichnyapp for gifting five
subscriptions
on twitch as well yeah i mean this is
it's extraordinarily disrespectful to
all of these reporters
we know that this administration doesn't
actually respect the press
so it's not altogether surprising that
that's what they're doing
uh but it is extraordinarily
disrespectful
let me say a huge thank you to kat
tomzack
who's new member number 43 today on my
website joinedpakman.com
also glenn banish and derek flores have
gotten us to 45 new members today
we do have a very ambitious target of 50
but we're almost there we are very very
close
as we stand by for kaylee mckennany um
who is now almost an hour late almost an
hour late on
truly unbelievable if you're just
joining us
uh i'm being very careful about what
video i play but there has been a
gigantic explosion of what appears to be
a fireworks factory in beirut
take a look at the video it is shocking
[Music]
absolutely
blocks away kilometers away reportedly
people have been injured kilometers away
if you can imagine that um
okay people are talking about whether i
like rage against the machine yeah i
like rage against the machine yeah
mike b pyro says what do you think about
trump's kids letting him fail to get
control
letting him fail to get control of his
money i don't know anything about that
dan says hey david i had a question
about your sponsor blue chew could you
in great detail explain your experiences
before and after using the product thank
you i
i have not used the product i admit and
i don't claim to have used the product
uh very important but were i a user of
the product i would tell you
nothing to be uh nothing to be ashamed
about but i have not
tried it mario ramos has signed up at
the soyboy level
megan curran says it must take so much
restraint for the reporters at the
briefing to remain
calm kudos to them for not losing their
cool
lies and delays galore we are now
a full hour late for this press briefing
a full
hour they have never been this late i
think the previous record was about 45
or 50 minutes
they are now a full hour late
disgusting absolutely disgusting
i do want to say thanks to
uh thomas ganter who is new member
number 46 today
at joinpackman.com thanks thomas i
appreciate that
and um looks like reporters are trying
to communicate with each other here
maybe determine
how long it might be until this starts
it's really anyone's guess
i mean they're 61 minutes late at this
point
and let's see what it is that they're
trying to explore here
yeah it's it's i mean it's crazy people
are still kind of milling
around let's see if we have any
different angles it looks like the
camera people are getting in place so
that's sort of a good sign
fox news hasn't even started their
stream yet which is not a good sign
that's very much not a good sign um
oh okay this is the technical person
helping this particular reporter
looks like with the camera being held up
maybe maybe it's going to be happening
very soon
can you i mean it's just an hour late an
hour late
thanks to clay h20 for subscribing with
twitch prime
also thanks to tomorrow's trials for
subscribing on twitch
damian mcdermott says bluechu is awesome
there you go great
uh they've been a great sponsor we
actually uh
i mean listen they're not going to keep
advertising with us
if they're not getting any sales so uh
what can you do lorna morgan says there
is video on bbc news website the
devastation is awful
yeah we've played a couple videos now it
isn't it i've not seen anything like
this recently
confirmed not fireworks david pakman
i've not uh i've not seen that
let's see massive explosion massive
explosion
shatters windows shatters windows
i'm i'm still not seeing anything
official about what it is so i'm going
to reserve judgment i don't see any
advantage to uh
speculating at this point in time tommy
arredondo says what's the main thing
biden could do to get some of trump
supporters that used to be obama
supporters
just being i i don't think he has to do
that much i think he's going to get most
of them
by virtue of being obama's vp
stone the forbidden says are these
delays a deliberate flex on reporters
your guess is as good as mine lorna
morgan has also subscribed on youtube
at the soyboy level
and uh k ray as well as circle hair guy
have subscribed over on twitch if you
were just joining us
this is an hour late now 63 minutes late
for the press briefing
there has been a major major explosion
in beirut lebanon and
we are just now learning let's refresh
this and see if there's any more
information
footage shows blast shaking beirut
footage shared on social media captured
the explosion
one video filmed from a nearby boat
appears to show a white pawl of smoke
rising over the city seconds later a red
plume of smoke can be seen shooting into
the sky
followed by a massive explosion yeah
this was the instagram video we played
unbelievable and then there's the red
plume
truly shocking truly shocking
and then on a much lighter note a much
much lighter note donald trump
can't say yosemite when they gaze upon
yosemites yosemites towering
sequoias yeah yoseminites so
things going bad at the massive scale
and things going bad at the micro scale
um let's see here mark anthony says keep
it up mike greco says what's lewis up to
these days
uh louis what is lewis doing he's he's
uh hit by the virus right now
his work is closed interestingly enough
matt cleric says washington post youtube
channel has a live
has live aftermath coverage max trades
any chance this is an act of malice by
the trump administration to call it an
act of terror and delay the election
i don't think so but i think until we
have more information we shouldn't
speculate
rob thomas has signed up on youtube m
redmond says washington post has a live
stream of the aftermath
danny thompson bloomberg reports that
beirut's head of
of general security said explosion was
not due to fireworks as reported earlier
okay
important news biakasha
okay random question here are you a big
horror movie fan
no all right here we go
[Music]
hello sorry to keep you all waiting
before
i begin it is day 42 of the botched
new york city primary where still there
is no
election results in one congressional
race
this as the new york times notes is due
to quote the deluge of 400
000 mail and ballots previewing the
quote challenges facing the nation as it
looks towards conducting
the november i addressed this on my show
today so i won't interject here
um now i'd like to highlight the trump
administration's actions on telehealth
which the president detailed yesterday
the president signed an
executive order to make regulatory
reforms allowing for greater
access to telehealth than toward making
it permanent
the trump administration has cut red
tape allowing telehealth services for
seniors and for other americans
35 percent of medicare beneficiaries
took
advantage of the president's reform
seeking telehealth
services over the phone rather than
through video conference
a simpler and a smarter way to go about
things is now available
to medicare beneficiaries the president
also took
executive action to boost rural health
care services according to a 2019 study
by navigant
rural hospitals would be devastated uh
by medicare for all otherwise known as
government takeover of health care
um and under that analysis they found
that if democrats had their way
imagine with everything that's going on
just talking about telehealth 1037
hospitals across 46 states
would be at high risk of closure the
president's executive order calls for
strategic investments in our rural
communications infrastructure which will
expand
telemedicine and rural broadband access
democrats seek to deny americans their
health care
freedom but president trump is working
hard to save
your health care by guaranteeing
protections for people with pre-existing
conditions
eliminating the highly unpopular
individual mandate of obamacare
stopping surprise medical billing
increasing transparency and lowering
drug prices
president trump will continue to work
hard to enact these health care
principles by requiring price
transparency allowing states to purchase
drugs from other countries and improving
medicare to lower drug prices
and reduce out-of-pocket costs for
seniors total gains and by ending
surprise
medical billing and making companies
compete for your business
by providing more options and more
affordable plans
lastly later today advisor to the
president ivanka senior advisor to the
president ivanka trump will be joined by
attorney general barr
director of the domestic policy council
brooke rollins
executives from organizations that
combat human trafficking
and survivors from across the country
for a round table to highlight
newly awarded department of justice
grants to provide
safe stable housing to survivors of
human trafficking
doj will award over 35 million in
housing assistance grants for victims of
human trafficking
to provide supportive housing and
appropriate services
to survivors of human trafficking and
with that i'll take questions
thank you bailey uh two questions about
the coronavirus
uh the president of the minneapolis
federal reserve he said two days ago
that he believed that the only way to
have a real strong
robust economic recovery would be to
shut the country down again for a month
to six weeks
i know that this idea of short-term pain
for long-term gain has been shot down
before by president trump but
has has it been given any more
consideration
given the recent politics across the
country no and i would refer you to what
uh
dr fauci said back in may he said we
can't stay locked down for such a
considerable period of
time that you might do irreparable
damage and have unintended consequences
including consequences for health and
several of those consequences i've
outlined for you
uh before um for instance the fact that
in any given year you have 120 000
americans who die from
drug um overdose or suicide and we saw
during the lockdown previously that
we saw overdoses nationally jump by 18
in march and 29 in april 42 in may
overdoses do go up suicides do go up
cancer cases are missed as dr
scott atlas has pointed out um that
in the u.s alone there are 150 000 new
cancer cases they're acting like we had
some prolonged national shutdown we
never had it we had sort of sporadic
state shutdowns that overlapped with
each other to different degrees
it's like we ne she's acting like we've
been shut down for six months and we
can't do any more identified so there
are many health consequences those are
uh three of what are a long list but so
no matter how bad it gets you don't
think there's
any way that president trump would look
at it i'm certainly not going to engage
in hypotheticals but
no the president is not considering a
national lockdown what he is encouraging
is mitigation efforts um like wearing a
mask which is patriotic like social
distancing
and engaging in these really common
sense uh safe measures to
safely common sense of masks which trump
ignored for five months
down okay and one more thing about the
negotiations going on today on capitol
hill
given the amount of money that is
involved the amount of americans that
would be impacted by this next
uh stimulus bill why isn't president
trump more
more personally involved or at least
more visible
in these negotiations well he is through
his chief of staff and through his
secretary of the treasury he's regularly
updated
i was just in oval office with him and
the chief of staff was
updating him on that very measure but
right now the democrats are being
fundamentally unserious they've offered
no concessions they've offered no plans
if anything they put out a plan two
months ago you ignored it trade their
own seriousness their three trillion
dollar plan they've now said oh
needs to be 3.4 trillion when the
president has had
a very narrow specific focus right now
it's
extending unemployment insurance it's
making sure americans don't get evicted
and when democrats as i noted on friday
were offered the martha mcsally bill
which would have been extending
unemployment insurance for at least
seven days while these negotiations
continue
that was rejected by chuck schumer which
should tell you exactly where democrats
stand and it's against hard-working
americans who lost their jobs
does anyone even take kaylee seriously
the president about 10 minutes ago
tweeted about
vote by mail absentee voting he says in
florida the election system is safe and
secure
tried and true what in his view changed
was he advised by republicans that he
was potentially suppressing his own vote
by stoking unfounded fears about mail
and voting and will he admitted now
is the fact that voting across the
country
by mail is safe and secure and tried and
true well the president has always said
that absentee voting
for a reason is different than mass
mail-out voting like what nevada is
seeking to do which leads to mass
it's the same thing and also um i'd
refer you to the campaign on this but
there was a victory
with regard to ballots so i believe
that's what he was referencing would
refer you to the campaign for details
on that but he's been unmistakably clear
that when you have this mass mail out
voting like what nevada wants to do the
consequences
are real um when the las vegas journal
review
uh was reporting did extensive and very
good reporting on nevada's first
all-male primary election
they note that there were photos of
ballots tossed in trash cans
littering apartment mailbox areas dozens
pinned on the complexes bulletin boards
i'm in various apartment complexes um
and and you have a postal worker who
said that
um when she went to go deliver some of
these ballots in several cases people
had moved or died she kept 65 ballots on
her first delivery
100 on her second um it is riff
with fraud um with delay if people died
or moved they wouldn't be voting
anyway like the the this is uh i spend a
lot of time on the podcast today on this
so i'll try not to now narrowly rare the
president votes by mail
you vote by mail and a dozen other top
trump administration officials vote by
mail
so um with regard to the absentee system
that's right and there is
ample evidence of fraud i would point to
the best example of this and very recent
was may 12 new jersey's special election
in paterson new jersey
where one in five mail-in ballots were
found to be fraudulent in the election
new jersey officials were charged in
that case
and resident ramona javier said this
this is corruption this is fraud there
people were caught that's like saying
don't build houses because sometimes
smoke detectors work and detect a fire
these people were caught
a ballot there are ample examples of
fraud and we can get those two more than
just patterson new jersey
another another question on a different
issue what can the administration tell
us about the
deadly explosion in beirut what led to
it so that was breaking as i came out um
we're tracking it closely and um just
rest assured that we're taking a very
good level
so that apparently wasn't the delay
thank you the environmental bill the
president signed this morning it was
passed
overwhelmingly by both houses of
congress both republicans and democrats
signed on to that legislation
can you explain why there were no
democrats at the ceremony or even
mentioned
in the president's remarks um the
president is very proud of what happened
today the single largest investment in
america's national parks
and public lands and history uh the most
significant
conservation achievement since teddy
roosevelt won the support of more than
850 uh conservation groups and it
provides 900 million a year
and permanent funding to the land and
water conservation fund and you're
asking about recognition of
congressional democrats right now
and the only thing that we're
recognizing about congressional
democrats right now is how appalling it
is
that there are americans who are going
without paychecks because they refuse to
partner with martha mcsally
wasn't the question and ensuring that
those payments go out
the president has said um in recent as
recently in this axios interview that he
believes that there
that many people believe that there's
disadvantages to testing can you walk us
through
uh what those disadvantages are and if
as he stated back in june he still
believes that testing is overrated and
makes the us look bad
so i would know what the president um
refers to with regard to testing is that
um you know the media doesn't often
acknowledge that when you do
do uh the most testing in the world lead
the world in testing
uh that you do identify more cases so
that is
what he refers to um with testing and
he's made that point a few times
um but look we lead the world in testing
and the president's very proud of this
uh the administration is very proud of
this we've done more than you guys know
you're being propagandized too right
like i hope
nobody in my chat is falling for this
million by september that's
extraordinary
um and when you compare that to the next
highest number india
in the ballpark of about 16 million
tests what we've done in this country is
impressive
and the president is very proud of that
effort people believe that testing in
the u.s is
overrated the president again points out
that the media refuses to acknowledge
that when you test so much you do
identify more cases
that's the point he was making and he's
very proud that actually by the way what
does it mean that the media refuses to
acknowledge that that's
such a stupid meaningless phrase percent
worth mentioning this is a novel virus
there wasn't a test and this president
led the way and getting emergency use
authorizations to one
that applied to every country it was new
in every country other countries dealt
with it better it's not like it was
unique that the u.s didn't have a test
and everybody else did
thanks kayleigh on tick-tock the
president has argued that the united
states should receive money in return
for a potential sale but
he hasn't really explained how under
what authority could the treasury
collect fees from china
from microsoft or from any other u.s
buyer um
to get this done as the president
demanded so i'm not
going to get ahead of the president on
any official action but he has
made that point and he and both
secretary pompeo have said
uh that the u.s act the u.s will take
action in the coming days
on chinese apps including tick tock tick
tock excuse me due to the national
security risk and we all agree that
there needs to be a
change especially with tick tock
collecting significant amounts of
private data on users it's unacceptable
but i won't get ahead of the president
on what those actions look like
thanks very much i wanted to ask also on
to talk about
uh beijing has said that it may hit u.s
firms
as a response it sort of slammed this
smack you know smash and grab of
tick-tock
what do you say to that uh in regards to
china and
secondly china has not complied with
its uh commitments under the u.s china
phase one trade deal
we're reporting today that you know
they're gonna completed five percent for
instance of the energy
purchases in this first half of the year
can you just sort of say
yeah we um encourage china to fulfill
their obligations and the phase one
china deal
i've seen people walking around with
that mask i don't know how it takes that
shape where it's almost like a duck's
bill based on
tick-tock and protecting the private
data of millions of people in this
country
and prc's um the people's republic of
china's laws require chinese companies
to cooperate
with prc security and intelligence
services enabling the ccp to access
foreign user data and what this means is
that these entities ultimately answer to
the ccp
which actively undermines u.s interests
and is hostile to american values
and the rights of individuals and the
president will stand firmly against
china on this can i just guess john
thank you kaylee i wanted to ask you
about the
covid relief bill the president has
suggested if there is no
agreement uh that is reached the
president would act
unilaterally as you know uh the power of
the purse resides
with congress so what would the
president do
unilaterally explain what you could do
unilaterally
as it relates to providing relief to
just about everything
just about every question is some form
of trump claims to be doing something
that there's no legal framework or basis
for how exactly does he plan to do it
but um what i would say is this is you
know right now we have secretary mnuchin
and
chief of staff mark meadows once again
um asking nancy pelosi and chuck schumer
to come to the table
the ball is in their court here we've
made at least four offers
they've made zero offers it's
unacceptable for hard-working americans
kelly on mail-in voting which you talked
about at the very top
of the briefing the president uh
suggested yesterday
that he has the right uh to
write some sort of an executive order as
it relates to
male invalidity right can you explain
what would empower the president
in the constitution to take some sort of
executive action
as it relates to mail-in voting again i
won't get ahead of the president on his
actions um and what those actions would
be and i'm not going to
get engaged in a hypothetical as to what
the actions would be and what
authorities they would be based upon for
yet to be announced
actions but just to once again
underscore the president's concern when
you look at the delays
and voting in pennsylvania a very good
report by
cbs zach hudak he got a quote from
luzern county manager david
pedry who oversaw or who
identified some of these delays that
they saw in pennsylvania with mass mail
and voting
and he said this quote i have this
nightmare of cnn fox cbs and everyone
else
waiting for these things to come in on
election night and we don't have them it
is very hard to speed up this process
so then you wait a few days and we make
sure that the results are right i'm fine
with that who cares
we've seen in pennsylvania as we've seen
in new york as we see across the country
the president's very concerned about
delays and outright fraud
he suggested delaying the election may
the president said yesterday in the
briefing that was
that took place right here in the
griefing room the united states
should get a very large percentage of
that price
because we're making it possible and
that was referring to
microsoft's proposed purchase of tick
tock
i've never heard of that before and
maybe you could explain that to me how
the government
could get a percentage of the price
of a private transaction can you explain
i'm going to get ahead of the president
again on this
action yes francesca haley i i want to
ask you something about the executive
orders but i do want to follow up on
kristin's question
and just get a better understanding of
what the president is doing personally
to make sure that those extra
unemployment benefits
are reinstated is he calling uh
senators on capitol hill does he have
any plans to meet with nancy pelosi
or chuck schumer personally and is the
white house concerned
that all parties will be blamed if there
is no deal and voters will just stay
home in november
no one has worked harder to ensure that
those payments get to americans than
this administration
um chief of staff mark meadows secretary
treasury
um steve mnuchin have been on the hill
many many days now
trying to get this deal worked out but
it is
democrats it is nancy pelosi it is chuck
schumer that are making an
absolute mockery of this process trump
literally golfed saturday
and sunday this past weekend extension
of unemployment insurance
they are moving beyond what their
initial request was of 3 trillion
and then they moved to 3.4 trillion they
wanted 100 billion dollars for schools
and we offered 105 billion to which they
rejected
they are making a mockery of this
process we're still engaging with them
but this president has been clear um
he's ready to act on this
and it is of paramount importance to him
and again
why would you reject martha mcsally's
clean extension democrats are
fundamentally unserious and they're
making a mockery of the crawling them
okay then if you don't want to if you
don't want to move on that with regards
to the executive orders
the president has signed a flurry of
those recently he said yesterday that he
expects to have a health care plan by
the end of the month
and also an immigration plan by next
month does the white house feel
a sense of pressure to get everything on
the president's to-do list done before
november
no no but the president moves at a very
rapid pace
um and he wants to get as much of his
agenda accomplish this term and going
into next term
this president's done a lot already but
he will
work on covid and alongside that many
other issues as he routinely does this
administration often is accomplishing
items on two or three different topics
in a day as you can see today
with the human trafficking um the event
this morning and then um also
i have an announcement the president
will have a covet briefing at 5 30.
but um i do want to just step back and
say this um with regard to covid i think
it's really important to put the
successes of this administration in
context and i got some new information
from hhs just before this is a scripted
walk-off right
you know this was a novel virus there
were no tests there were no therapeutics
but what did this administration do um
we as i noted
earlier surge testing increased it by 32
000 since march hhs is predict
projecting 100 million tests completed
by september
because of president trump's tearing
down of red tape
there are more than 230 clinical trials
of potential
covid drugs and biological products are
underway
and over 510 are in the planning stages
today nia
nih announced two separate covid
treatment trials um
active two and active three and these
are monoclonal antibody treatments
and also by september we have secured
more than half a million courses of
treatment of rem de severe um that is
one of the several therapeutics that
this president has achieved um and
finding for the american people to treat
this
novel uh disease this novel virus and
the vaccine again moving to phase three
clinical trial
at the fastest rate for any novel virus
in history this could only be
accomplished
by president trump by a businessman in
the white house who is not only
uh on the race to get a vaccine we have
two and phase three clinical trial but
is securing
a hundred million doses um in advance so
that we're ready to ship them out
um this president has been hard at work
on covet along with a number of other
issues and those
eos will be forthcoming
which i don't think israel israel
reopens
in schools these are open schools israel
from schools and they got and they had
issues with that there were
outbreaks students got sick what do you
think of the fact that
you um i called on you and you didn't
ask your questions and then i proceeded
over another reporter i wasn't gonna do
that so do you not want to answer my
question now that
i was not being rude to another okay
um the president said that he could
interview with axios that he's doing
everything he can do
to address uh the virus is that really
true i mean is there nothing more that
he can do
at this point and um also is he willing
is that
does that does that suggest that he's
willing to accept the number of deaths
that we're seeing
no we are hard at work each and every
day uh to defeat the invisible enemy and
in fact um just to give you an update on
some of the actions
uh we've taken right now there are
currently 28
220 us government personnel deployed
for coven 19 response on top of that
next week dr burks has visited states
across the country and next week she'll
be visiting
indiana ohio kentucky tennessee
and virginia we're hard at work at again
getting more euas
for more treatments and therapeutics and
testing
um so we every day we're rapidly looking
at
how we can make this the the most robust
response and the history of this country
and i think that we've done that when
you look at ram desabir in the
therapeutics at play and the case
fatality rate
uh is really indicative of what this
president has done when we
remember cfr we should be looking at
deaths per capita you remember that i'm
sure
bridge of the world um and below europe
uh that shows that our therapeutics are
working rendezvous convalescent plasma
and dexamethasone uh this president's
hard at work and he'll continue to
work hard none of that stuff has
anything to do with trump i think there
are still
waits for getting test results back when
you have declined to pose it
to impose a national mass mandate when
you're saying you won't shut down
the entire country again so um with
regard to testing and the timing uh when
we identify a problem
we quickly identify a solution and oh
yeah uh like for example
in in february we didn't have enough
tests and we still have a five to seven
day delay yeah real quick
testing we already lead the world in
testing so to increase the speed
we move towards pool testing and that's
the flexibility with which this
administration adapts to
problems we identify on the ground and
we rapidly develop a solution
to ameliorate the problem yes thank you
would the president like to see mitch
mcconnell put the
uh 600 extension of the unemployment
benefits
through the end of the year on the
senate floor to put the democrats
in the spot of having to vote for that
clean extension
so i haven't talked to him about that
proposal and i don't want to get into
the middle of the negotiations
but what it's safe to say is there's
been one proposal
one clean proposal to extend
unemployment insurance
uh that was put forward by martha
mcsally the president was ready to sign
it and it was rejected by chuck schumer
and nancy pelosi
i follow up and just asked on a slightly
separate topic
whether or not the white house has a
view on whether or not
members of the media a pool should be
allowed to cover the republican national
convention's official proceedings
which apparently as of right now because
of the space limitations the
the convention committee is saying that
that's not going to be possible
i'm yeah i'm not read into the
convention discussions but i certainly
will inquire about that and follow up
with you and find out what the status is
yeah
thank you yes um thank you so much haley
um
do you have anything with regards to the
massive explosion in beirut that
we already said now again that was
breaking as i came out here and
safe to say we are monitoring the
situation yes
thanks for calling on me um i wanted to
give my question over to you
sure that's fine wow um so my question
is on two questions the first
question is israel opened its schools
back up they thought they had the virus
under control
that virus then spread and it became an
outbreak students got sick
they had to close schools down how were
you that what happened in israel might
happen here given the fact that there
are experts in israel who say
they made a mistake there well i would
refer to our experts and um
cdc director robert redfield um answered
um i saw a picture of us ben dixon
actually posted it
of uh school open in georgia today it's
just a mass of people in a hallway all
packed together with no masks
the world it is in the public health
interest that these k-12 students
get back to schools that are open for
face-to-face
learning i want these kids back in
school it is paramount
uh to the health of the child the
president just tweeted to
you answer a question about this mail-in
voting or absentee voting whatever you
call it he's saying
essentially it's the same thing so why
is it now something that can be done in
florida but not in other states why is
that
the appropriate thing to do he's not
saying he's always made the distinction
mass mail out voting
is with nevada where ballots are mailed
in mass out to the voter rolls so in a
place like la for instance where 112
of la county is registered uh ballots go
out and at least 12 percent of those we
know are not active
voters um so that is the distinction um
from
absentee voting which is where you
proactively request an absentee ballot
there's a
difference there and the president the
president repeatedly makes the
difference and he is also noting
as i told jeff you can follow up with
the campaign on this but there was a
a victory um in the courts in florida
and that's what he was referencing in
the tweet
yes thanks kaylee you mentioned
extending the eviction moratorium and
unemployment
insurance on saturday trump tweeted
payroll tax cuts
plus dollars is a payroll tax cut still
on the table
um the president would love to see the
payroll tax holiday because it would in
fact benefit low and middle income
americans the most but right now his
keen
and laser focus is unemployment
insurance and evictions those are the
preeminent priority
especially with that friday deadline
that nancy pelosi uh
missed pelosi
thank you this administration has worked
too
has identified human trafficking as a
crisis and has worked to combat it it
looked like she turned to a particular
page
even before knowing the question because
is it scripted in advance with oan
platform that enables sexual
exploitation of
young people especially in america
would this administration ever consider
if tick tock became a u.s asset would
this administration ever consider rules
or imposing rules that would help
mitigate this risk against young people
on the platform tick tock
yeah i haven't spoken to the president
about that specific
fact scenario um but absolutely it is a
priority for this administration to
combat
um human trafficking and the
exploitation of children so
we would certainly take a close look at
that um but i
i have not talked to him about that
specific fact pattern um
i would like to end just by highlighting
a troubling trend that i think we've
seen
play out across the country and i
believe we have a few graphics to
illustrate this
um it pertains to the defund the police
movement
and when you look at across the country
the ties of defunding the police with
increases in violence it's a cause for
concern
remember nothing's been defunded yet so
it you can't link it causally in this
way
bring in the defund the police movement
in los
angeles you had la mayor eric garcetti
proposing a cut of 150 million
from the lapd la mayor garcetti said
this
can you imagine if you wanted to commit
a murder
and you hear that there's a proposal to
defund why would you go and commit the
murder now wouldn't you wait until the
police has been defunded like how
you'd have to be an idiot to say oh in
the future there will be less police so
let me go kill someone now
movement was a foot as well with a
unanimous vote in minneapolis city
and their council to dismantle the
police and you had
minneapolis city council member jeremiah
jeremiah ellison saying this is one
action of many
all right guys this is actu this is
literal gutter trash so i'm not even
going to broadcast it for you
i'm i i'm sorry that she was an hour
late uh i do appreciate that you were
here with me
that this is this will rot your brain
this is worse than anything i can
imagine
um so i'm not going to play it for you
but i may be back later today
for the trump cop fee stream or or maybe
not i may be streaming later with alex
botez
for my chess tournament preparation or
maybe not on the way out
please do follow my channel on twitch
we're trying to get to 50 000 followers
and please do hit that subscribe button
on youtube it's free you'll be notified
of future streams i hope
to see you there and we are in a race
against ourselves
against time to 1 million subscribers
on youtube so please do hit that
subscribe button
as you head out uh kaylee mcinanny
wrapping up here
cities and it's not acceptable thank you
very much and you'll see the president
at 5 30.
there you go so complete and utter total
trash um to the extent that
that was um you know
i i'm everything is crazy everything i'm
gonna go curl up in a ball now because
that was just
absolutely insane but thank you for
joining me subscribe and follow we'll be
back later
you